[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this is you i smoke a cigarette and i
play ipad
lately troll you little late night
booger
don't make fun of me dude i had to go to
the hospital
okay the hospital
they confirmed dogs can't get corona
they can carry it huh cats i don't
really care about cats even a little bit
they can get it in fact i hope every cat
gets it okay i want to say this right
now i hope everything
gets corona
you know what it is
[Music]
i hope they're walking around all
limping like yeah yeah
you view cats like asians it's the same
[ __ ]
[ __ ] face
i want to see i want to see videos of
cats online with corona yeah yeah just
their little leg
and they're coughing
have you ever left a movie
about a hundred times well you just
stood up star wars
which one
the second one second or third which one
was the one that came out and
it came out here we'll ask
one of the resident dorks down below
it's the one that i almost walked out i
think is the same one
it's the one where princess leia flies
in space yeah whatever that was
yeah yeah
once she did that
and she did that like mary poppins like
flying through the space get out of here
i i i stood up i left and i was i was
making a decision i said i don't know
that's ridiculous so annoying that's not
a force no right i'm gonna go and then i
would i was with people just leave i go
you want to go
and they're like nah
all right you stayed
you're a good friend
oh it just got worse and worse and then
like there was a part part in there
where like um what what which one was
that they went to the casino when they
went to the you know where they had the
fat chubby asian chick yeah which she's
great actress by the way and she got
roasted online yeah right well you
didn't help just now
by the way neil brennan sent me
um a video on youtube that came out a
week ago what
theo's family theovan's family do you
want to see it yeah yeah this is crazy i
know his what his mom looks like so this
is his whole family on youtube yeah look
at this
this is theo vaughn's whole family oh
yeah yeah i've seen i met i met the oh
wait
that's his uncle in the red it's his
uncle yeah right there that's theo's
uncle
there
is that theo's brother or dad on the
couch that's his uncle the guy in the
red right that's his mom right there in
the blue right so what are your names
his brother yeah he's up to the right
okay yeah and in a second his brother
will hide
all these stories growing up where his
brother hides years ago watch the video
is that my brother used to run and hide
dude he gets so scared
lightning claps or even lawn mowers will
do it yeah
and your name is
lauren
yeah yeah that's his aunt and there's
timmy his brother his brother timmy and
you guys grew up here in uh in odd west
virginia so let me explain for people
that can't see it that are listening at
home there's a video that neil brennan
sent me yeah this is called the
whitaker's it's the mo they quoted them
as the the most inbred family in the
united states they have the longest
lineage of inbred
it's pretty brilliant
it is brilliant their eyes are like
hammerhead sharks
i know what if the tv fell on the dog
the dog meanwhile you're playing
i'm 50. i like ipad games at 3am you're
you're in shut up shut up
shut up rudy do you like your new
painting yeah
i did i went to the er honestly no but
look at my eyes busted for the fans yeah
and i went and got my skull and my
noggin checked and i went in an imaging
machine
and i was scared because the only one
they had was in panorama city you can
google it it's not nice
and i got nervous
the whole time so when it gets let me
just ask and they send back the results
and they said you're fine but you have
an overwhelming amount of stress in your
blood level do you by chance work with a
korean mandate on a weekly basis
i said yeah i work with a little troll a
little booger-eating troll
in a room in the valley and they said
that could be part of the problem you
don't you don't know all dressed holy
[ __ ] do you guys know all dressed all
dressed is the most popular brand in
canada it's salt sea salt and vinegar
barbecue sauce yeah it's like combining
both of those chips it just seems like
something that white people would like
it is that's what we invented almost
everything so i'm gonna pass on it
you're gonna what kind do you want
fish sauce chips
wasabi
flavor
no no and then when you said earlier
before the cameras were on um i said
we're hunkering down we're making stuff
and you just said
out of the blue you said
dog
why would you say that because you said
we're making we're making stuff at the
top out of the blue i just said dog i
know but no no it's a term of endearment
like my dog no you're my butt i don't
think that what is i did see the video i
did i did see a video this morning a
girl sent me what of them cooking a live
dog in china oh there's videos
circulating now all the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
they're doing
you know what it's like
you know you've heard of the yulin dog
eating festival yeah
what the [ __ ]
what did you place when you were over
what did you place were you first or
second third third i took i took a
bronzer
yeah yeah yeah but you know what threw
me off in the third one is when i saw
the trailer for the third one coming out
yeah and at the end of the trailer you
do you remember what you heard someone
laughing
no
the emperor oh
right and i'm like
he's alive he's alive yeah they just
gave that away the emperor's alive
the emperor
the one that got thrown yeah in that
shaft in electricity ah remember is it
electric is that what i remember he was
like zapping luke oh yeah yeah he was
zapping luke right with the [ __ ] right
yeah his wizard [ __ ] right
right he's like no no whatever he was
doing luke right and then [ __ ] anakin
or darth vader
not my son right he picks up right the
emperor throws him and and the emperor's
flying was still with the electricity
right yeah right with the electricity
[ __ ]
falling right
this is how far chicky falls
times ten
times ten right yeah it probably hits
the asphalt it implodes yeah right
exponent
whatever right whatever he does then you
hear
in the [ __ ] trailer he's alive he's
alive
he's [ __ ]
alive
so i but i saw it anyway we've got our
spanish shirts on
do you like it
it's not really that spanish it looks
like somebody
that a homeless person in bangladesh
would wear it you know what i mean yeah
like it you know it has this
third world quality which i love third
world wear but you know
it's it just feels like it's just
patched together you can buy this on the
streets of calcutta yeah yeah yeah
meanwhile i think he told
like you're you're if you're with a
prostitute in calcutta
you need to get no no and you can you
you like come on the wall she gives you
this to clean it off
this is a dark thing but um i did i
don't know why i thought about this but
let's just post bestiality
just hear me out oh was a huge thing in
the world what do you mean like a normal
because right now there's probably seven
dudes who do it yeah you're crazy
in new zealand apparently yeah a lot of
farmers [ __ ] sheep okay i i don't want
to know that but uh let's just assume
it's
let's just assume it's 20 dudes okay all
right
now let's jack it up to a million dudes
do it
okay so it became like a normal thing
it's kind of normal in some semblance of
society yeah i think the one animal that
would be completely just
off-limits no
you'll be they would just be extinct oh
because of that because of it is the
sloth right because they're so easy to
catch they don't they can't go anywhere
they can't i mean because sloth they go
well sloths live in trees how can you
get them because i thought about this
right
honestly i don't know why i thought
about this but
in papua new guinea there's a lot of
slots right i didn't know there is right
yeah so what they would do if they would
go to papua new guinea right and slash
you don't know i googled this i don't
know why i don't know why it's
researched this but sloths they come to
the ground while they take a [ __ ] or
they go to the bathroom i've seen this
right i've seen this in costa rica they
come to the ground right yeah so imagine
a bunch of sloths in the tree right
where you going johnny
it's lots like i gotta take your
i'll be right back and as soon as he
lands get him 50 dudes come out they
form a train yeah right
and then he trying to run away
right
and he's like and his buddies are going
run
frankie
i'm
trying
to run
right and he gets on the tree
right he's already been raped 40 50
times right
and people are like jumping up and
tagging them
right and just ripping them as he goes
up the taller the taller guys
yeah the tyler guys right
i mean that would be a nightmare they'd
be extinct
bro i can't wait till you pass out and
get hurt
and i like bro
hey bro man hey bro hey bro hey bro man
you selling me a car hey bro
white people i don't have a lot of
friends
dino
you know this right juliana knows this i
don't have a i don't talk to a lot of
people right
and um i have
you know maybe four friends yeah
um you're a part of that infrastructure
i know a friendship right it's very
difficult to get into that kingdom
you know the kingdom is closed for um
enlightened hierarchy
do you think it's because most people
don't want to get in that kingdom
anymore there's other ones available
maybe
but
but i still have a very strict
dress code you have
a dress code yeah
you know philosophical code okay okay so
it's like just imagine me being a
kingdom
right you're being a gate a king or i'm
a king you're a king and there's a gate
yeah
and people walk up knock knock knock
hello
can i be bobby's friend yeah and then
there's you have to go into a room
you take a test what's the test oh
there's a mill do you know there's 10
questions pretty much
there's 10 questions what are they um
do you know what
what the first question is
chicago pizza
or detroit pizza chicago
there we go
so i passed yeah you passed number one
okay all right number two it's rolling
stones or the beetles neither trick
question that's exactly what it is
exactly what it is all right right yeah
number three um
what is the most important area of the
genitalia the [ __ ]
the taint
or the head of the penis
there's another quick question it's all
the above
[Laughter]
that's what i'm saying
kingdom is exclusive yeah it's very
exclusive well i'm glad i'm your friend
well there's also physical challenges
i'll kiss you
yeah yeah
ming one day i came home
and she just was just sitting there and
she goes yeah
like welcome home
and
i [ __ ] fell in love with this thing
man
she's like i love me more than most of
my cousins
like if my cousin andy died
yeah if my cousin andy died just listen
to me man yeah i am
this is
call me call you're my other cousin tell
me if andy died
call me
hello
hey bob what's up dude why are you so
sad oh man you won't you want a burrito
right
you want to breathe
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah what happened andy died
what yeah and they died
and he died all right well
you know okay well i'll talk to you
later okay okay hang up yep
playstation
beyond jokes it is insane to think that
five generations
will have sex with their family yeah
five times five decades of people were
like okay
it's not fair because i'd have never
been to odd virginia i can't westbrook i
i see it i get it there might be there's
not it's not as if there's like suicide
girls walking around
where you could tap them
there's probably only the whittakers
okay you're saying you're saying you're
only as good as your opportunities well
the options aren't who are you gonna
[ __ ] not your family yeah but if there's
no one around not your family i don't
know but just hear me and you feverishly
masturbate until you die let's see let's
say i just let's say i had a sister all
right we're gonna have to put music over
this
i'm just trying to play it out of my
head yeah but but look let's just play
it out of my head all right here we are
in odd virginia no we're in um
[Music]
yeah it's an asian community in west
virginia west virginia right
well how do you do a
japanese wells from virginia
it's a southern japan
yeah yeah so okay so you're out there in
west virginia
and i uh i don't go to school yeah
there's no school no schools and they're
the only families are the lease right
and the junks i know that yeah lee's in
the jungle yeah yeah they're there yeah
right but the jungles only have boys
all boys yeah are all boys and the lees
have my brother steve now is a girl
yeah what's happening stephanie right
stephanie lee right
and um the jung's you know
i [ __ ] everyone already though
in town or the fan oh the giant job so
the entire
so ken bob steve kevin mark and
randy and randy yeah yeah yeah yeah and
uh when you're done for some reason
vladimir
there's a vladimir he's like i love to
see you yeah
and then you know um the only woman
women around is my mom
and the jungle mrs jung this is john oh
that's right this is john yeah yeah and
then my sister stephanie right on
so after them after you knock out the
mods i'm 33 i i i just decided to drink
some um
you know moonshine not moonshine um
it's a japanese one uh uh uh uh
yeah
yeah
to a little too much sun yeah yeah
having a night i go
i have to do an asian summer
hey
[Music]
stephanie oh yeah oh yes brother
good night
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and the horse
penetrates him so hard it punctures his
stomach lining
and his organs and his stomach all came
out of his ass yes and he died yeah it
makes perfect sense right and then what
the police had to do is go to the hotel
and inform his wife and his daughter
okay what's that what's the i don't i
want to be the police i want to be the
police
hello what it's it's
it's 3 30 in the morning i'm sorry uh
are you mrs jefferson
i am is something wrong
yeah and uh you're the wife of todd
todd jefferson yes that's my husband
todd jefferson what oh my god is he okay
was he dreaming again but no he there
was an unfortunate incident oh my god a
dui did he hit anybody no he's a
terrible alcoholic and i know that's a
big vice of his we're trying to get him
help and good god i hope he fixes his
issues
oh god did he hurt himself punctured by
horse dick um what
i'm sorry pictured by a horse dick
he was punctured
what are you saying to me officer he
the dick you're the horde you know what
he was driving drunk he hit a horse and
the horse's penis killed him
no not necessarily though you know let
me do you know about the horse anatomy
of course yes horses have penises
sure the males that penis of a horus yes
punctured
the stomach lining
of your husband
what was he doing near the horse of a
peanut a penis of a horse
stretching oh he was just getting ready
for the big game no he'd been over
you're telling me my husband was having
sex with a horse and i killed him
yeah
i should have i should have directly
told you that
that's my bad now
the fact that you had to dance around
but imagine if the cop was like this if
it was just
yeah
hello yes
what time is it hello you barbara
jefferson todd jefferson's wife yes i am
yeah your husband's dead he got [ __ ]
to death by a horse we got to wrap this
up
they just throw it away they would just
throw it away that's why i don't like
now asian horror movies
why because the characters in the asian
horror movies don't seem as scared
right someone's like oh and they're just
like oh
no but like if they're zombies right
we'll fight back
zombie right and they'll pick up a sword
hi
hi hi hi right where's white people
would run yeah right yeah so they don't
seem as scared to me and who lives the
whites
the whites live that's true and the
asians are like
they get festive did you know that
men who love cats are more college
educated and smarter than the the where
did that statistic look at the stats
look at the stats bro look at marlon
brando
marlin brandow bro
right yeah sir patrick stewart stewart
picard
picard he loves cats brah okay yeah he
loves girl gray too there's plenty of
smart guys that love dogs
yeah but it just statistically
smarter people i'm not buying into this
google it you're you're so fast at
[ __ ] googling [ __ ] google it [ __ ] how
could you what would i search tell me
what would i search george what would
you say what could i even search what uh
uh
cats owners cat owners average
intelligence versus versus owners versus
dog owners versus
oh we're gonna get the dumbest results
yes this is gonna be some [ __ ] the
research revealed that the owners of the
two animals have to have different
personalities cat lovers being more
sensitive and open-minded and then dog
lookers who are largely energetic that's
right carroll university in wisconsin
cat owners scored highly on intelligent
then dog owners there we go
right but also we go but also and more
sensitive and what open-minded you're
that's what i told you about bill
o'reilly earlier dude you're a
closed-off angry man in fact
fact oh look at this
uh a study by keller university also
found that people
who like cats in general tend to be
total [ __ ] losers
if this happened to you what would you
do okay okay
your mom decides at midnight
to chop vegetables
oh i'm leaving no i really wrecked it
down there i'm leaving
why are you up chopping vegetables at
midnight right what are you doing and
then what kind of kid are you to not go
what are you doing mom what are you
doing yeah we don't you're making the
post pot roast now
right so in silence right she was
cutting so they go to bed the adult
children like no big deal yeah cut you
know she's going through something okay
right
and then she starts cutting
faster
yeah and then it starts going fast
and she goes past the onion
right right she goes past the onions
cuts off the dad's dick no and starts
chopping her own fingers
right but not just one part just like
it's like diced onions slice and dice
yeah yeah
the kids wake up and they go to the
kitchen
and they see
beautifully sliced onions
beautifully sliced carrots right
with fingernails and [ __ ] finger pieces
i think big pieces of finger and blood
all over the place right and they're
like these
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] going on right yeah
and then they they go mom
right they yell out into the farmlands i
don't know what they call it farmland
sounds right
yeah yeah they yell out in the farmlands
yeah mom
mom
and they're just you could see them
running around right
and in the distance you know they got
the camera cuts back pans out well the
camera's in a i guess a farm house
right it's zoomed into them yelling mom
and as it peels back you can see the
feet of the mom dangling from the farm
she hung herself
because she cut her hand no we don't
that makes sense
how does that make sense because if you
accidentally cut your finger and you're
like oh god i gotta kill myself
right it's embarrassing the next step
yeah the next step
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way i know
[Music]